I think our viewers and listeners could
use some good news today and we have a
little bit of it here earlier a few days
ago the US Supreme Court ruled that
North Carolina
Republican state lawmakers unlawfully
disenfranchised specifically black
voters when gerrymandering their
congressional district lines
gerrymandering we've talked about it
before this is the practice of drawing
congressional or state legislative lines
in a very strategic way to favor a
particular candidate or party we've done
a long-form piece about it we've done an
interview about it and we've especially
been talking about it with respect to
the upcoming 2020 census and the line
drawing that's going to follow in 2021
this might ring a bell because this was
the Supreme Court holding upholding the
prior decision made by a US District
Court in February which at the time we
reported you Republicans unlawfully took
race into account when creating two
majority black congressional districts
in 2011 after the 2010 census and the
court ruled unanimously on the
unconstitutionality of one of the
districts the other district had a 5-3
ruling with three conservatives
dissenting interestingly and
unfortunately the US Supreme Court has
never actually said that state lawmakers
can't gerrymander legislative and
congressional lines to favor one party
over another so the legal problem here
is specifically the racial issue it is a
win but it's also sort of a
disappointing confirmation of reality
which is you can draw districts to favor
one party as long as it isn't based on
race in 2015 the Supreme Court threw out
a similar lawsuit against Alabama for
doing the exact same thing to black
voters so this is progress in a way and
and when you look at a map of North
Carolina's 13 congressional districts
which our TV audience can see now you
can clearly see these are the the two
yellow districts are the ones that were
in question here and I'll describe them
to our audio audience you have one that
is incredibly narrow and is basically
touching one two three four five six
seven other districts this little sliver
of land and then you see another
district and
yellow in the northeastern part of the
state which sticks out into very
specific cities and towns in a way that
again is making the surrounding district
more white and more likely to all go
Republican and concentrating the black
voters within these two districts so
this is great but again this is a map
that was drawn after the 2010 census its
2017 that means that these lines have
been in effect for years a lot of damage
has been done these districts were in
place in 2012 in 2014 in 2016 as far as
the federal level in intra North
Carolina elections
additionally beyond that and that's part
of the problem right North Carolina
Republicans drew these lines in 2011
they were probably aware that they were
doing something that was questionable
legally but they know it's going to take
in this particular case it was six years
we will get a number of congressional
and state legislative wins before the
Supreme Court if they ever do will make
a decision about this they still won and
that's why the US Census that's coming
up in a few years is so important that's
why we need to reform our process when
it comes to drawing district lines and
of course gerrymandering takes three
different forms as packing stacking and
cracking yeah I think this is a clear
example of packing because if you're
able to put the african-american
communities into two distinct districts
then of course they're going to be very
influential in those districts but as
part of the state overall
not so much state legislatures can
consider race when drawing lines if it
helps them comply with the federal
Voting Rights Act but Republicans were
doing the opposite here right they were
drawing lines based on race in order to
silence and disenfranchise black voters
and these discriminatory lines are in
addition to constant attempts by North
Carolina Republicans to pass voter ID
laws that would suppress black votes
last week the Supreme Court ruled that
the strict voter ID laws proposed by
North Carolina Republicans were
unconstitutional and unfairly harm
minorities so it has been a good week
for voting rights in North Carolina more
than seven years after the
census that led to this in the first
place for now it is I mean the problem
here is that it comes down to a judges
interpretation some of these states and
jurisdictions have laws where these
districts have to be compact and
contiguous yeah but outside of that
there's not much regulation when it
comes to this sort of thing and the
mindset is well I know a good district
when I see one when he has a lot of
these judges and obviously different
judges have different political leanings
of yesterday day I to pretend that they
don't yes they do and to all the Bernie
or Buster's or the never Hillary people
out there this is why Supreme Court
appointments matter what are the chances
that Donald Trump cares anything about
appointing Supreme Court justices who
would rule against this kind of racial
gerrymandering his record on voter
suppression suggests that he wouldn't
care about that and this is exactly why
we need to be aware of all of the
repercussions of these sort of
Manichaean black-white perspectives on
never this or always that or whatever
these are multi-generational impacts
that happen as a result of who's on the
Supreme Court yeah when it came to the
2016 election a lot of people were just
focusing on Trump's past and Hillary's
past their expertise in different forms
and their reputations it matters a lot
more you know who gets the majorities in
Congress who is going to go on Supreme
Court all these other things matter
no probably more absolutely we've got a
great bonus show planned for you today
the American Legion calls on Donald
Trump to take cannabis off of the
Schedule one list of drugs to help
veterans a belligerent man in a trump
hat was kicked off of a flight set to
leave China to come to Newark as the
rest of the people on the plane shouted
shouted lock him up and the Texas
Legislature has eliminated straight
ticket voting all of those stories and
more on the bonus show sign up a david
pakman.com slash membership and follow
me on twitter at D Pakman today's
program sponsored by none other than
Casper mattresses I've been sleeping on
a Casper mattress since I moved to
Boston in November of 2015 the mattress
I got a king mattress and it showed up
in a box that certainly doesn't look
like it could contain a king mattress
but it does they use some amazing
technology to
squeeze the mattress into the small box
it shows up you open it and the mattress
just expands and then you've got a
king-sized mattress there or whatever
size you have they have the supportive
memory phone which creates an
award-winning sleep surface with the
right amount of sink and the right
amount of Bounce you can try a Casper
mattress for 100 nights risk free in
your own home if you don't love it I
loved it if you don't love it they'll
pick it up and refund you everything
Casper understands the importance of
sleeping on a mattress in a real way
before you commit especially considering
that you're going to spend a third of
your life on it roughly free shipping
and free returns to the United States
and Canada with over 20,000 reviews and
an average of 4.8 stars it is quickly
becoming the Internet's favorite
mattress and you can get $50 towards any
mattress purchase by visiting Casper
comm slash Pakman that's PA KMA n and
using the offer code Packman PA que ma n
terms and conditions apply support the
david pakman show by supporting our
sponsors